elle n'a pas perdu sa journée en
accompagnant une partie de sa famille
provinciale pour une troisième visite de
la tour eiffel je parlais de jacqueline
martinez qui a reçu pleins pleins de
cadeaux aujourd'hui en effet le hasard a
voulu que cette femme de 33 ans gardien
de la paix est et le 150e millionième
visiteur de la vieille dame de fer
allemands nico si c'est l'histoire de
jacqueline martinez qui fait la queue
sous la tour eiffel vers 18 heures pour
la reconnaître c'est facile c'est la
147e à gauche arrivé à la caisse il ya
de la joie des caméras des photographes
ambiance comme à l'elysée vous savez à
la sortie du conseil des ministres
jacqueline 33 ans gardien de la paix
originaire de carcassonne a gagné le
droit de passer à la télé sans 50
millionième personne à visiter la tour
eiffel surprises et quelques mots
forcément historique
comme ça
je sais pas quoi dire
c'est la première fois que vous veniez
de trois fois
pas de triche possible un conteur marc
chaque entrée au rythme actuel les 200
millions seront franchis le 18 septembre
2004 jacqueline et sa famille ont eu le
droit à l'historique la technique du
monument jérémy quatre ans est très
passionné aujourd'hui c'était la fête
des adultes jacqueline n'a rien vu trop
de monde mais elle reviendra sans doute
demain discrètement